President Trump speaks to the annual
CPAC meeting of conservatives this
morning after saying schools need to
protect themselves from violence a
gun-free zone to a killer or somebody
that wants to be a killer that's like
going in for the ice-cream
president door sledding train teachers
carry weapons when he met with state and
local officials yesterday that idea has
people split along party lines according
to a CBS News poll out this morning 44
percent of Americans favor teachers
carrying guns 50 percent are opposed the
poll also finds 65 percent support
stricter laws on gun sales that's the
highest number ever recorded in our poll
up 8 points since December Julianna
Goldman is at the White House Julianna
good morning good morning you know even
as the president says he's open to
measures opposed by the powerful gun
lobby
he is most forcefully and
enthusiastically backing a proposal that
the NRA pushed in the wake of the
Newtown school massacre arming trained
teachers we have to harden our schools
not so for the moment
President Trump doubled down on an NRA
backed proposal he first mentioned
Wednesday in an emotional meeting with
survivors of the parkland Florida
shooting arming staff in schools we need
to let people know you come into our
schools you're gonna be dead and it's
gonna be fast teachers who agree to
carry a weapon would get training and
financial incentives you give them a
little bit of a bonus most of the state
and local officials at the meeting did
not object but the president didn't
provide a price tag or propose how
school districts with limited resources
would fund it there are over three
million public school teachers
nationwide and 400,000 in private
schools arming 20% of them as mr. Trump
suggested Thursday would mean more than
700,000 people with guns in schools this
does not pass any common-sense test
whatsoever the National Education
Association said more guns in a school
is not the solution the problem is that
very dangerous people have very easy
access to very dangerous weapons
at the White House the president pushed
back against the idea of active shooter
drills in schools I wouldn't want to
tell my son that you're going to
participate in an active shooter drill
and I think it's crazy I think it's very
bad for jr. the president also called
for raising the minimum purchasing age
of an assault type weapon to 21 and
insisted the NRA would support him
despite their current opposition to such
a move and the NRA will well back in I
really feel very confident the president
spoke with NRA s leadership after last
week's shooting and yesterday at a
gathering of conservatives just outside
of Washington the NRA s Wayne LaPierre
echoed some of the very same talking
points as mr. Trump viana he said the
only way to stop a bad guy with a gun is
a good guy with a gun yeah he has said
that before and of course the president
will be speaking at CPAC today and we
will be covering that Giuliana thank you
so much